ashwitha a very difficult start for you
to this tournament but finally you got
that breakthrough how does that feel
I thought I had I think I just played
well the first game and I should have
won that with Bishop takes H7 so that
was disappointing but it's nice to get
an attacking win finally what did you
feel up to this point that wasn't
clicking for you in this event was it
the opening was it the middle game well
it wasn't clicking I think opening wise
I was coming out with like good
positions and at some point I think like
after two or three hours of play I just
my brain stopped working and I I saw the
move that I was supposed to play and
then chose a different move and I think
it could just be lack of practice or
something not entirely sure but yeah
hopefully I can start winning more games
now well absolutely today it felt like
you came out with guns blazing out of
the opening with a very aggressive
stance that move H4 as well this line
with H4 against the Karo Khan was this
in your preparation were you expecting
her to play the Karo Khan I actually
wasn't expecting her to play The Carol
um I was expecting the French or the
Petrov because I think that's what she
normally does and I think when she went
with the Carol she was expecting me to
go the two nights that I did again with
another three nights yeah in like two
days ago
um and I mean I got it like a slight
pull there in that game but not enough
to like convert so I decided to be more
aggressive I've never played this before
in my life and I actually don't know the
opening that well but I play the Carol
from the black side so it was kind of
familiar and then after you've analyzed
it but from the black side so after age
six I remember there's some G4 but I
didn't I thought that might be because I
didn't know what was happening so I
thought that might be too risky so I
decided to just go this bishop D3 take
take and then play with the pawn on H5
and I got like some similar position
against Anna last year just slightly
different piece placement and she
allowed me to go F4 F5 again today as
well
um and I think she wasn't so familiar
with the position because she was
spending a lot of time absolutely and
here I think you are playing quite
quickly one hour and 25 minutes already
heard down to her last 57 minutes and
actually got much worse later on in the
game 23 minutes at this point and this
is only move 16 and you you still had
more than one hour one hour and 10
minutes and you were breaking through
you were feeling quite uh well at this
point I would assume right yeah I was
just when I was here I was I think I was
after night of
um I was considering Knight E6 but I
thought it might get messy after Knight
takes E5
um
and queen E5 because I can't take the
road because the queen G3 very nice so I
thought
so I thought not to make things messy
for her especially because she was low
on time so I played the simplest which
was my tix F5 yes
um now I'm turning 96 as well as uh
Knight E6 and so she took on D4
um and here I was
after uh Queen B6 I was debating whether
to take on E7 Bishop E7 Knight D5 Queen
e6's force and I even saw Queen F5 here
but it doesn't work because the queen
isn't pinned
um
yeah
um but here I was looking at Queen C4
King V8
um this is probably also better but I
just decided to play Knight D there's no
killing glow at this point right there
was no killing blow and I Knight D6
Knight F7 seemed convincing and then I
saw this she had this Knight E5 but I
think after Queen B3 the problem is if
Queen takes D4 Bishop E3 and there's
also mate on B7 that she can't stop
point to E4 she can try but you were
actually first yeah to her King and
after that she played uh King to ba this
was the position
exchange the Queens that's an extra Rook
a full Rook nice conversion ashrita uh
what does this Victory mean for your
tournament and what are your Ambitions
after let's say five rounds going into
the first rest day um after the first
three losses in the first half
um I'm just playing a game by game
coming into the tournament the goal is
to win the tournament
um but I think right now I'm trying not
to think about that goal even though it
hasn't changed and there's still a lot
of trust to be played and I've had
terrible starts before so hopefully I
can come back again absolutely still
eight rounds for you ashwita
congratulations and we'll see you in the
rest of your games thank you absolutely
our congratulations as well as srita